まあ私は今紹介してくださったように
m の業者というのをいただきました
けれども
今日はですね
あの
まあ今日はちょっと違う話をさせていき
たいとおもいます
皆さんは今
こちらを見ています私は反対に皆さんの方
を
ゴミているわけです
今私たちは同じ場所に行って同じイベント
に参加しているわけですけれどもそれぞれ
の目に映る光景っていうのは全然違います
見る方向つまり後視点が違うわけですから
当たり前ですよね
今日私がお話ししたいことはこの当たり前
のことなんです
このもう当たり前すぎることが実は
とんでもなく奥深かったということ
これを
これまでの研究生活っていうかねその経験
からお話ししたいというふうに思います
まあ事あるごとに何度も何度も
アンダーラインを引きなおしてきた
そして再確認してきた見方を変えると見え
方が変わるということです
私はだいたい30年ぐらい25年くらい
から
単細胞生物の研究をしてきました単細胞
いいましても僕のことではありませんよ
あの年金と言います
お金の話ではあります
あの非常にねまでました巨大なアメーバ様
生物いうのがおりますでこれをまあずっと
研究しながら
まご飯を食べてきたわけですですからまあ
人読んで私は年金生活者いう風
ありがとうございますこれだいぶ
リラックスできましたそれで皆さん年金
って聞いたことはありますかいます
a
お金じゃない方ですよありますかすごい
ですねこんなん意外なほど良い2割ぐらい
の方は聞いたことがあるというわけです
こんな生き物です黄色く見えてるものが
ありますね
これが一つこんな大きいんですけども一匹
の巨大な幹細胞アメールわけです見た感じ
は絵馬ベタベタしたマヨネーズみたい
な姿敵
ですからこの写真もですねどちらが年金で
どちらがマヨネーズか全然区別がつかない
で同然単細胞ですから脳や神経っていう
ものはありません
で単細胞という言葉を広辞苑で弾きますと
考えの単純なことという風に書いてあり
ます
ですはい僕もそうなんですけどそれで
まあでも考えてみますと単細胞生物
この地球に現れたのはもう何億年も前の話
私たち人間の何百倍何千倍も長い間
ちゃんと生き抜いてきてるよー
そう考えると我々のめっちゃ先輩なわけ
ですね
ですよねー
だからそう考えると少し見え方が変わって
くるんじゃないかっていうふうに思うわけ
です普段はこんな風にして買っています餌
はオートミールこの白く見えてるつぶつぶ
がありますでしょ
このひとつひとつがオーツ麦っていうまあ
麦の一種それを乾燥させたものですこれを
与えますとそこへ年金を集まってきて養分
を吸収して大きくなってあちこち子動いて
いくっていうふうにしますでこういうのを
毎日1回生はしながらまあ何年も何年も
年金を買い続けてきたこれは非常に健康な
状態
こんな風に
こんな形で元気にな姿を見せてくれている
今まぁこんな感じって僕は言いましたで
ある時ですねふと
こんな感じってまあどういう感じなのかな
自問自答したんですね
よく見るとですね
年金の
体の中に筋のようなものが見えますでしょ
これ血管のようになっていて中を栄養とか
情報が行き来しているわけです
でこの管
なんとなくですねあちこちに散らばった
オートミールを
なんか繋いでるようにできている
もしそうだとしたらこれはどういうふうに
繋いでるんだろうかいうふうにます思った
でそれは年金にとってどういう生理的な
良いですね彼らにとって意味があるん
だろうか
でもし餌箸をうまくつなぐように欠陥も
作るとしたらこれは年金にとってですね
どういうふうに繋いだらいいのかっていう
ひとつの解くべき問題
その問題をどういうふうな
計算方式というか
解決方法で答えを導き出しているんだろう
か
などなどなどですね次次に具体的な問いと
なってですね言語化されたものが頭の中に
こう
立ち上がってきたんですねでひとたびそう
いうふうになりますともうそういう考え
抜きにこの年金の姿を見ることができなく
なった
皆さんも先ほどからこの年金の姿をという
かまぁ見てますけれども最初と少し違って
見えるようになってきてませんか
きっとなっていることと思います
でまぁ何ずっと僕はこういう年金の研究を
してきましたけれども今が研究をしてきて
何が楽しいのかというとですねこれに見え
方がどんどんどんどん変わってくるんです
ね
新しい問題意識を出して見え方が変わって
いく世界の名方が際限なく変わっていく
これがやっぱり一番面白かった
これが僕にとって一つの大きい見方を
変えると見え方が変わるっていう瞬間でし
た
でこれはですね一匹の錬金が a
迷路の中に閉じ込められている
赤いところにこれから餌を置きます赤い
ニコニコマークのところ皆さんだったら
どうしますか
これお腹が減ってて
下さが欲しい
年金は4時間くらい経つとこんな形に
変わります行き止まりのところに伸びた
からだを引き上げて餌の上に移動していっ
て養分を吸収するですさらに時間が経ち
ますと米ぬコレ4つのですね
2えさ橋をつなぐ接続経路すべてをに管を
つくってそこを示しているわけですね
さらに時間が経つとこのうちの一つだけを
選んで
しかもそれが一番短いけるそれをとって
その他のところはさの上に入って養分を
吸収するという形
とにもかくにもこんな簡単な実験から年金
にはメールの際關係ろたんさいぼうですよ
探し出す計算能力があるっていう事がまあ
わかっ
でまぁなかなかやるだやるんじゃないやる
じゃんっていうふうに思ったんです
まずですねこの時に思ったのは広辞苑を
書き変えなきゃいけない
でこれどんな風にステージや問題を解いて
いるのか最短経路を探しているのかって
いうわけですけれども
越冬
これ自律分散方式の解き方ということが
分かりました年金欠陥がありますこれは
ですね流れが活発だと太くなるし流れが
あまり活発でないと細くなるという性質が
あるということが分かりますそれだけで
最短経路が導かれているということなん
です
つまり
札の血管の部分部分ですねそれが繋がった
ものが年金の総体体の全てっていう風に
なっているわけですけれどもその部分の管
それは自分のところの流れだけ new
反応して言えば身勝手に太さを欠いている
にもかかわらず全体としていいかいが出て
くるわけですねそのありの管がどういう
状態かという事は一切感じ
こういうのをですねまぁ自律的に太さを
変える管があちこちにあってそれで
答えを出すという意味で自律分散方式と
いう風に呼ばれています
まぁこシミュレーションの表すです
でこれを見つけたのがまあ15年ぐらい前
ですでずいぶんまあ興奮してですね
ワクワクしたのを覚えています
ところが残念ながらですね
まあ業界の人はほとんど振り向いてくれ
なかったんですねそんな乞食が悪く何とか
7年ぐらいあったその間ですねええ
この業界にとどまるって言うんですかこう
生き残るためにまあそれなりに苦労したね
その時に
まあ心の拠り所として思ってたことは非常
に素朴ですけれども
どこかにですね学問
鍵様がいて僕のことを見ていてくださる
もっと端的に言うとへ
お天道様が見ててくれる
だからまあもうちょっと頑張ってやってみ
ようっていうふうに思ってやってきた
で
まあそういう虫とは別にですね虫ほとんど
無視されてたっていう状況とは別に
僕自身の年金に対する関心というのは
ますます深まっていったですでこれはです
ねもうちょっと餌場所が沢山あった時に
これ36個ありますけれどもそこを年金が
うまく餌場所ですねつなぐっていうそう
いう絵柄になっていますで3つ特徴があっ
たんですねひとつはちょっと理屈っぽい話
ですけども全体をなるべく短い距離で
使い魔つなぎましょうっていう経済性
2番目はどこか方まさか断線した時に切れ
た時にですね
どこかに迂回路があって全体のつながりが
維持されるというまあそういうある種の
補償に対する耐性
三番目はですねえさ場所2つとってきた
ときにその距離がなるべく短い距離で
つながって行ったほうが良かろうっていう
高率ですねこの3つを甘く見たしてこの3
つはですねそれぞれを
ベストな状態にして実現するってことが不
可能な問題なんですね年金はそれをうまく
だけをさせてどれもそこそこ
を実現しているような年金へネットワーク
作っているということが少
これなかなかすごいでもご気づき
いいかもしれませんけれども
この餌場者の配置っていうのは
関東圏の主立った街の分布それに合わせて
置いてあるわけです
とすればへ
この年金の形と実際の例えば鉄道網の
ネットワークこれを比較してみることが
できる
早速行ってみた
そうするとわかったんですその非常に鉄道
もが良くできているということが
年金程度によく的
でこれで驚いたのは単細胞のアメーバーの
研究を増してきたわけですけれどもその
向こうにですねまあ人間社会のやっている
ことねそういうものが少し透けて見えてき
た
これからやっぱり
人間社会のやっていることのに対する見方
が少し変わってきたね
でこの研究をしている時に
このネットワークの形をどんな風に評価
しようか最初アイディアがなかったわけ
ですね
で
こういう年金の実験年金が作った
ネットワークの形の写真というのを撮り
まして大きく引き伸ばしましたででその
数字に合わせてですね e toko おい
て言ってその糸の長さを測るこういうて
作業を何十枚何百枚の遮蔽に対して1枚1
枚やってるだけです
出そうの頃同業者はですね
そういう作業というのは時間の無駄だ
画像処理で
やれば一発でわかる
こういう作業はですね人間性をむしろ阻害
する人間のやることではないというふうに
は言われたんですね
半分はそうかなと思ったんですけれども
少しそれが違う風に思っ
ずーっとこう一枚一枚の写真にえーい手で
なぞりながら年金のネットワークの形を
a
追体験する
いうことをやっていますとまぁこんな感じ
のつなぎ方だよねっていう風感覚が高
芽生えてきたとかそういうことが思える
ようになってきたんですねこれって
6色のところでこの形に対する理解が何か
進んでるっていう証拠だと思うんですね
でそういうものがあればそこのからですね
何か言語化したこう味方問題意識を
引き出すことができるかもしれない
ひとたびそうなればそれはもうこの問題に
対して見方を実際に変えてってくれる糸口
になるというわけです
ですからこういう方ものの形に触れるどう
していいかわからないけれどもずっと増え
続けている
その時間というのはとても大事なもの
だろうというふうに思うわけです
そこを画像処理で一発でありますと
何もですね
6色のところの理解が
すまないいうふうに寄付したりします
でまぁこんな年金の研究をしてくると年金
法式の解き方っていうのを例えばカーナビ
ね
カーナビに使ってみたらどうだろうかって
いう可能性があったりするわけですはじめ
はですね単細胞にの技術をですね我々のか
ナビに使うなんてことは思ってもみなかっ
たわけですけれどもこういう可能性が
枚出てきたんですね
実際はあんまり開けてないんですけれども
あなたの道
あの売り込みに行ってるんですけども
なかなかあのはい
まあ世の中なかなか厳しいんですけれども
まあそういう風になって
で
でもですよいつか皆さんのカーナビを
開けるとマヨネーズみたいなものがドロッ
と入っているということが
こないとも限らない
ぜひ来てほしいと思うんですけど
でまぁこんなことをやりながら
きたんですが
まああの
いいときもあればそうではなかった時も
あるわけですね最初の6年7年はほとんど
まあ無視されてたわけです
でそういう頃にですね
僕がそもそも何がしたいのか
何が何をやっていると幸せなのかっていう
ことを言えば自問自答するわけです
初めはよくわからなかったんですけれども
だんだんですね
わかる意識できるようになってきたで自分
の原点研究の限定は何か1つはですね
皆さんもご存じだと思いますがファーブル
昆虫記っていうのがありますこれがあの
はっきり原点として意識できるような4
ファーブル昆虫記2つ感心することがあり
ます
一つはですねごくありふれたすぐ
近くにある何の変哲もない空き地荒地で
彼は研究なしていたということもう一つは
へ
観察
肉眼の観察と簡単な実験で皆さんみんなが
驚くような非常に明快な結論を導き出して
いるということですこれはだから誰でも
やろうと思えばできたんですよね
でもファーブルしかできなかった
それはそういう見方がやっぱり必要だった
わけです
ですから
ファブにとってはなんの変哲もない単なる
あレーキって言うんですかあの草地って
いうのは存在しなかっただろうというふう
に思うわけですそこにはめくるめく虫の
ですね必至の生活
驚くべき生活がもう見えてたと思うんです
ね
ファーブルしか見えなかった世界を彼だけ
が見てたということなんだろうと思います
こういうはまぁ見方なんですね
どんな風にまあ
自分自身探していったらいいんだろうかと
いうことがもう一つの問題なんです最後に
そのことを話したいと思いますでまぁ原点
という意味でいいますともう一つ別の側面
があります
僕は小学校の時に一番好きだった強化が
図画工作
なって
ね図画工作がある日はもう前からですね
ウキウキして今日は学校へ行きたいって
いうふうには思ってたわけですね
べ図画工作
まぁ最初創意工夫します
その後て作業ですねて作業ずーっと地道に
あのう投げ出したいっていうことも置い
といてですね積み重ねていく
最後に作品ができる
そこその作品はもう
見れば見るほど自分の自己表現になって
でその作品を
かえして
言葉ではできなかったコミュニケーション
が他の人と取れるということも分かった
そういうことはですね今の研究活動とまぁ
非常に重なるところが多い
だから僕のやっていることはその頃小学校
の頃の図画工作のまっすぐ延長線上にあり
ます
創意工夫する時の頭の使い方と新しい見方
をなんとか作り出そうという見方
頭の使い方これは全く同じものです
で作品ができた時に
心が満たされるその満たされ方それと研究
が論文としてまとまって発表できた時の
やっぱり心の満たされ方っていうのは
やっぱり
全く同じものなんですね
でこういうのをどんなふうにして自分自身
探してきたか思うとですね
最後は自分の感受性が耐えたより知的感受
性みたいなものが頼りだったっていうふう
に思います
小学校の頃もですね机にし座りながら
ミンターなんかすごいな思って自分一人が
ですねを取ってるなーっていうまあよく
思っていたわけです
みんなこんなふうにいろんなことを理解し
たり発表したりできるけれども僕が全然
できないなっていうまあそういうことを
非常にを考えそんなふうには僕は感じない
ぞっていうようなこともたくさんあったん
ですねでそういう自分をですねまあ dan
dan dan dan 心の奥底にご
しまって言って
あまり表に出すということがまあなかった
んですけどもやっぱりどこかでそういう
自分をまあかわいい
があると言いますが大事に思ってたんです
ね
で
そういう自分がいつも
最後は助けてくれたいいわけです
ですからまあ皆さんの心の中にもそういう
自分がいらっしゃると思いますいないわけ
ないと思うんですね皆さんの人格というの
は固有のものですから必ず固有の味方って
いうのがあると思いますでそういう自分は
年ともするとええええ暴走したりですね
すぐ心の中で迷子になったりしてしまうん
ですけれどもそれを務めてエマー
見失わないようにしっかり手を握って
抱きかかえて
やってきたというのがあの
これまでの研究生活だったのかなという
ふうに思います
以上ですどうもご静聴ありがとうござい
ました